le département de la réunion oeuvre pour
le développement et imagine la future
route des eaux de l'est une route
départementale qui s'étendra de saint
denis à saint benoît et qui concernera
six communes
[Musique]
cette route permettra d'offrir une
alternative à la route nationale st
denis st benoit saturé d'améliorer
l'accès au quartier des eaux
d'accompagner le développement de la
région et de valoriser ces sites
touristiques
le département a pensé une route qui
dynamise la connexion nord-est une faute
plus sûrs et adaptés à tous les modes de
déplacement et qui met en lumière les
paysages remarquables de l'est la route
des eaux de l'est sera une route
départementale à deux fois une fois
réutilisant autant que possible des
routes et chemins agricoles existants
afin de limiter l'emprise sur le foncier
agricole et urbanisé trois options de
tracés ont été définis à différentes
altitudes afin de couvrir l'ensemble du
territoire d'étude
la variante bat la variante médiane la
variante haute
[Musique]
en partant de ce pain de mie
en passant par sainte marie
[Musique]
sainte-suzanne
saint-andré
[Musique]
bras-panon
la roue des eaux de l'est va jusqu'à
saint benoît
[Musique]
cette étude s'inscrit dans une démarche
collaborative avant sa mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle
vous avez des idées des avis exprimez
vous sur le site internet
rha ou lors des réunions publiques du 12
septembre au 10 octobre dans les six
communes concernées à la cinor et à la
cirest le département aux côtés des
réunionnais